ونحن منذ ساعات الصباح ونتجول في هذه
المدينه المنكوبه بالكامل تقريبا نصف
المباني هنا مدمره وقسم كبير من المباني
المتبقيه مصدعه وغير صالحه للسكن هناك
حركه نشطه لانشاء عديد المخيمات كما في
هذه النقطه التي نتواجد فيها الان سانقل
الكاميرا زميلي
يحرك الكاميرا لنرى هذه الاليات الضخمه
وهي تبدا في تسويه هذه الارض التي نقف
بجوارها استعدادا لانشاء مخيم جديد
لاستيعاب الاهالي الذين فقدوا منازلهم في
هذا الزلزال المدمر كذلك خلف هذه الارض
ايضا هناك مخيم وضعته منظمه افاد او هيئه
الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه في هذه المنطقه
كما نشاهد الاراضي الزراعيه او الاراضي
الخاليه هي الاماكن التي يتم
يتم انشاء المخيمات فيها اضافه الى
الاسواق او الاسواق الشعبيه او ما تسمى
هنا في تركيا البازارات ايضا شاهدنا
مخيمات ونقلنا في النشرات الصباحيه شهادات
عدد من سكان هذه المخيمات حول الاوضاع
التي يعيشونها بالعموم كما تحدثت يعني
الحاجه للقيام او المخيمات
التي يعيشونها الان
نعم لا شك كان هناك تبايع في الاراء يعني
بعض المناطق التي زرناها هنا في اصلاحيه
الجميع كان يتحدث بان الاوضاع الجيده الى
حد ما استطاعوا الحصول على خيام وايضا
مواد للتدفئه نقاط اخرى انتقلنا اليها بعض
العائلات حتى الان لم تصلها خيام او حتى
مواد التدفئه لذلك الوضع متباين هناك من
استطاع الحصول على خيام ويعني الان الوضع
افضل من المبيت في العراء خصوصا في اليوم
الاول والثاني في
الساعات الثمانيه واربعين الاولى بعد
الزلزال لكن فيما بعد بدا الوضع
بالتدريجيا بالتحسن وبدات الخيام
والمساعدات تصل الى هذه المناطق طبعا هناك
كثير من المطابخ الميدانيه والمنظمات
والهيئات التي ارسلت مطابخ ميدانيه وايضا
هناك نقاط طبيه موجوده في قرب هذه
المخيمات
وعشرات الهيئات التي تساعد وتقدم
المساعدات في شتى انواعها حتى ان هناك
تبرعات وصلت
بالالبسه لمن يحتاج الى البسه سواء
للاطفال او النساء او حتى كبار السن لذلك
يعني الموضوع متباين لكن استطيع ان اقول
ان غالبيه السكان هنا في اصلاحيه
يتم استيعابهم في المخيمات فقط قسم صغير
حتى الان لم يتم استيعابهم في مخيمات وكما
نشاهد ان العمليه لم تتوقف عمليه انشاء
المخيمات كما نتابع عبر الشاشه هذه
الاليات تعمل لانشاء مخيم جديد ربما يشمل
بقيه العائلات التي لم تستطع الحصول على
خير لكن السؤال الاخر فاطمه هذه الخيم هي
حل مؤقت الان السلطات التركيه حتى لا يبقى
اهالي اصلاحيه وايضا المناطق المجاوره في
العراء هناك مرحله اخرى سيتم نقل هؤلاء او
غالبيه من هم موجودين هنا الى المناطق
وولايات اخرى ضمن السكن الجامعي في بعض
الولايات او ربما كما قال الرئيس التركي
في الغرف الفندقيه لحين البدء بعمليات
اعاده الاعمار ومن ثم عوده السكان الى
الجزيره التي ستهيئها من قبل الحكومه
التركيه حول اليه اختيار العوائل التي
سيتم نقلها اما هناك ربما افضليه للاتراك
ما هي الاليه تحديدا
حتى الان لا توجد يعني معلومات او اليه
معينه نحن شاهدنا في ولايات اخرى غير غازي
عنتاب في اديمان او في كهرمان مرعش يتم
نقل الجميع في حافلات الى ولايات بعيده عن
مناطق الزلزال واسكان
هؤلاء الاهالي في السكن الطلابي بعد افراغ
السكن الطلابي تقريبا بالكامل في معظم
الجامعات التركيه لاسيما ان الجامعات قررت
الحكومه التركيه وقف التعليم
المباشر فيها والانتقال الى التعليم عن
بعد